wherever this angle ends up see they're
gonna end up in the first quadrant
second quadrant third quadrant or fourth
quadrant okay wherever it ends up you
want to drop a perpendicular to the
x-axis okay and the angle that's formed
between the terminal ray where it
terminates or stops the spinner right
and the x-axis that's your reference
angle right there okay so this one you
would drop a perpendicular that's your
reference angle drop a perpendicular
seat to the x-axis that's your reference
angle drop a perpendicular to the x-axis
that's your reference angle right there
the reference angle is always going to
be an angle between 0 and 90 okay or
zero and PI over 2 it's always going to
be positive okay and that's the idea so
for example with 300 degrees what we're
going to do is let's go ahead and think
of this as a spinner so we're starting
here we're gonna spin that counter
clockwise because it's a positive angle
right positive so that's going to go 90
180 270 300 there's where it stops or
terminates we drop a perpendicular to
the x-axis we look at that angle that's
formed between the terminal ray and the
x-axis and that's going to be 60 degrees
you never want to go to the Y that's
going to give you the wrong answer the
nice thing about reference angles is
that this triangle okay it's the same as
this triangle okay and this is has
applicability when you look at the unit
circle and you start studying the unit
circle but this triangle this triangle
this triangle and this triangle if they
all have a 60 degree reference angle all
these triangles are congruent okay which
means that you know the sides of the
triangle are going to be congruent okay
all these are going to be exactly
congruent so I'll show you another
example let's do one with radians this
time so say for example you want to find
what is the reference angle for
two PI over three okay two PI over three
so we start here okay and positive
x-axis it's a positive angle so we're
going this direction two PI over three
so this is PI so two PI over 3 is like 1
2 3 PI over 3 so that's 1 PI over 3 2 PI
over 3 ok so we end up there there's our
angle we drop a perpendicular to the
x-axis and we look at that angle that's
formed between the x-axis and where the
rave stopped okay the terminal ray
that's gonna be PI over 3 that's our
reference angle PI over 3 now some books
and some teachers they advocate using a
formula they say okay if you are in the
first quadrant your reference angle is
going to be whatever your angle is theta
if you're in the second quadrant what
you're doing is you're going 180 minus
the angle okay that'll give you a
reference angle okay if you're in the
third quadrant you go okay let's say
your angles right here this would be
theta minus 180 that'll give you a
reference angle and if you're over here
you're gonna go to PI or 360 minus your
angle so you could memorize these
formulas I try to reduce the number of
forms they have to memorize just by
drawing the picture you can quickly find
out okay it's the angle that's formed
between where the Ray stops and the
x-axis but if this helps you go ahead
and use these formulas theta 180 minus
theta in the second quadrant theta minus
180 360 minus theta in the fourth
quadrant
so over here we could say alright we're
in the second quadrant so 180 is
actually PI minus our initial angle 2 PI
over 3 that's going to give you PI over
3 I'll show you one more example let's
do a negative angle this time say for
example we want to find the reference
angle for negative 210 okay so what
we're gonna do is we're going to draw
our coordinate axis we're going to start
here at the positive x-axis it's a
negative angle this time which means
we're gonna go this direction 91
80 30 more gets you to 10 okay 90 180 30
more drop a perpendicular and I can see
this angle is going to be a 30 degree
angle it's just 30 degrees past the
x-axis past 180 mark so it's 30 degrees
not negative 30 but PI so the reference
angle is always a positive angle between
0 and 90 or 0 and PI over 2 if you're in
radians so this has been an overview of
how to find reference angles you'll find
this helpful when you work with the unit
circle I'll see you in the next video